it's christmas in july so get out your
kraken energy drink and put up the
christmas tree because santa's coming to
town
american horror story's fourth episode
is out and i definitely have some
thoughts as i think this episode is a
great example of what's wrong with the
spin-off series so far
but also the potential that it has but
before we get to that we'll be taking a
deep dive into the episode and its
connection to the greater ahs
universe so make sure to like and
subscribe i come out with new american
horror story videos
almost every week welcome to the bro
house a satire on
influencer houses like jake paul's team
10. here we'll meet zinn
wyatt barry and james our very unlikable
protagonists for the next 40 minutes
these dudes are clinging on to fame as
they reach their 30s and in order to
keep their relevancy
have to up their game which is why zinn
suggests they videotape someone killing
themselves off the aptly named
bridge it's basically the whole logan
paul force video where he videotaped an
actual dead body
of all the characters in this episode
only one has been in a previous american
horror story
charles melton who plays wyatt was mr wu
in season 5's hotel
a womanizing ghost who offers sexual
favors from beyond the grave the guys
end up releasing the video at one of
their giant house parties but it goes
terribly wrong it seems people aren't
that interested in watching snuff films
this causes them to lose followers and
rethink how they're going to hold on to
their precious clout
we also get a new ahs intro it's shot in
a
aspect ratio to mimic that of an
instagram video there's nothing really
super interesting here
except for the introduction of the
hashtag santa stalker but we'll get to
him in a bit
berry here i'd argue is our main
character he's the only guy in the house
who's like hey guys
maybe we shouldn't tape dead bodies and
harass small santas but the allure of
the influencer lifestyle is ultimately
too
captivating for him and he easily gives
in to peer pressure
after they upload their controversial
video not only do they lose tens of
thousands of subscribers
but also their coveted brand deal with
kraken energy drink
rather than make an apology video the
guys go for a different tactic pretend
they're gay is a distraction
again this is pulled directly from real
life with celebrities like bachelor's
colton underwood and kevin
spacey both of whom used their repressed
sexual proclivities as excuses for past
inexcusable behavior one of the reasons
these guys became
influencers in the first place was to
get chicks and you can see their quote
homosexual plan
backfire when they're denied by a group
of girls so they need to come up with an
entirely new plan
wyatt suggests they go back to their
roots fun lighthearted pranks that made
them famous in the first place so what
do they do
harass a female elf a little person and
tell kids santa doesn't exist
no idea how they thought this would be a
good idea but it's here we get our first
look at danny trejo as santa who says to
zin
you'll get what you deserve before the
bros are quickly chased off by mall
security
now just for fun i went to look on imdb
at danny trejo's upcoming projects and i
kid you not
this man must be the busiest actor in
hollywood he has
26 different projects planned god damn
so now it's christmas eve and nothing
seems to be going right for the boys
their plans have all backfired
and they're bleeding more subscribers
than james charles hi sisters and just
take a look at this like to dislike
ratio for their latest video
slightly worse than one of mine zinn
receives a call from la homicide
detective dina gibbs
apparently the mall santa the bros
captured video of wasn't the actual
santa the mall hired
in fact it's a psycho killer who stalks
and kills other santas and takes their
place
he's left a special present for the
detective believe it or not american
horror story season 2
asylum saw a similar type of santa
killing character
season 2's lee emerson killed the santa
wore his suit and went on a rampage
killing 18 people
he also tied up a family in christmas
lights just like this santa will later
do with zinn
and christmas has been featured in other
seasons of ahs
including at the end of season 1 where
it's celebrated by the harmon family
as well as season 8's apocalypse bubbles
mcgee started a movie called a christmas
to dismember which was actually based
off lee emerson's christmas killing
spree wyatt goes into the garage where
his head is promptly twisted by santa as
a camera records the whole thing
the video is uploaded to their channel
where it immediately gains thousands of
likes where everyone praises the bloody
effects
zin goes off in search of wyatt while
barry and james uncover the true history
of santa claus
finding an article detailing his origins
as a pagan nature god who punished those
who were bad
maybe this is why santa ends up knocking
zin out with a giant bone
going back to those pagan roots it's
here where the episode really hits its
stride and where i felt it actually felt
like an ahs
episode zin is tied up in christmas
lights his mouth stuffed in mistletoe
and he's properly electrocuted in the
pool all the while this is being filmed
and uploaded to their channel as santa
sings god resty mary gentlemen a fitting
song for the bros
santa hunts down their remaining bros
with a candy cane crossbow
james getting one right through the head
barry escapes back into the house where
santa pours gasoline down the chimney
but right before he's burned alive barry
bassed in the glow of their channel
hitting
5 million subscribers even right before
his death the allure of influencer clout
is overpowering
in the end the bros got what they wanted
but paid the ultimate sacrifice for it
santa also leaves a present for
detective gibbs a christmas tree filled
with the body parts of the bros
and in the last shot of the episode
trejo santa stalks another santa
this is likely a whole year later since
christmas would have been over after the
events of the bro house massacre
now i have to say i was disappointed in
this episode i felt as though the entire
first half was filler
and that they should have started right
off the bat with the bros and the mall
santa incident i didn't care about any
of the characters and felt the story
lacked
well enough story maybe that's why the
episode clocks in at only 37 minutes
considerably less than an average ahs
but what i did love were the kills the
pool electrocution and candy cane
crossbow were excellent i just wish they
spent more time building
up santa but that may have been hindered
by paying for actor danny trejo which
would probably be expensive but if
that's the case
choose a different story or get a
different actor four episodes into ahs
stories and i feel the writers aren't
getting the structure of telling a
contained
story in 45 minutes the pacing has been
off in pretty much every episode and i
hope they can bring someone to really
structurally tighten
up the plots that being said of course i
love the ahs universe and i'll continue
to watch
and i hope you'll keep joining me too
thanks for watching everyone remember to
like and subscribe and for more bad
takes you can always follow me on
twitter and instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
you